hey chess friends national master james
canty the third here with chess.com
and today we have game of the day with
tata steel chest
2021 with the white pieces we have
andrey
yessipanko and with the black pieces we
have magnus
carlson let's get right into it guys
here we go e4 c5
knight f3 d6 d4 snap snap
knight f6 knight to c3 and a6
another one another night or sicilian
how many times have we seen this one
well let's see what this variation is
going to be after a6 there's bishop b2
from yesobanko
instead of bishop g5 like we've seen
many times already
this should be two very flexible move
not saying what we're going to do yet
and magnus responds with e6 instead of
e5 which is a traditional
night dwarf remove here now e6 is more
chevinningen variation here actually
which is a variation that gary caspar
views very frequently and very good
actually in his later years after using
the night or
now after e6 there's bishop to e3
keeping the development going
black says bishop to e7 for magnus here
if you're going to develop i'm going to
develop two and even try to prepare the
castle here
after bishop b7 yes p yes pinko says hey
you know what
before you castle let me give you this
real quick g4
g4 wouldn't move here actually just
saying hey if you cancel
you might be casting right into an
attack here so you want you might want
to be careful
before you cast so maybe do something
else and magnus obliges and says you
know what okay b5 hey
you know whoever gets to the king first
on opposite side castles is usually
going to win
but i want to be here at the party as
well b5 one of the moves that you
usually use in the night or sicilians
seven engines and of course a6 sicilians
but queen c7 97 bishop b7 this is our
common stuff
theory that you usually use in this
opening
b5 from magnus and g5 immediately here
from yesterpinko he says we're just
going for we're going to get as close as
we can
so if you castle you could be in a lot
of trouble so here's g5 and then knight
f to d7
the common move that usually happens in
the g4 variations of the night or
usually if you see an early h3 and g4
one of the best ways to combat it is
actually
what magnus is doing right here knight
f2d7 following with a development of the
queen side first all of the queen side
meaning rook to c8
queen c7 or b6 or a5 depending on the
position
and you develop the queen side first and
figure out what to do with the king
later
sometimes you don't even castle you just
keep the king here it depends on what's
going on but this is why it's such a fun
opening to play
because it's definitely dynamicism from
both sides after knight f to d7
there's this a3 move actually just
dropping upon here or at least
sacrificing it
unwillingly now you do have another
variation which is rich to g1 which
again deters castling here
in many cases and let's see what happens
after rook to g1 there's a b4 move here
which allows knight to d5 as a move
what is knight d5 why would i do this
there's a there's a pawn that could just
capture it
well this is actually a thematic
sacrifice that you see
many times in the night of sicilians
where you put a knight here on d5 just
to open up the game let's take a look
knight to d5 he takes d5 instead of just
capturing back which is terrible
well we're going to move this knight to
f5 very strong square deterring castling
once again but he says you know what hey
i'm a castle anyway
what happens you know i'm up a piece now
knight h6 looks cool but you don't have
enough pieces
so actually the best move the moon can
make here is queen takes d5
after queen takes d5 there is a rook
hanging but you actually can't even
defend it
rick a7 we're gonna just take it so
queen takes d5 and the knight to c5
being one of the best moves
and after knight takes c5 we take our
piece back and then
after takes takes there is queen takes
a8 here and we actually get some
material back we're feeling great here
we're up in exchange as
white as white says here so honestly
white's in a driver's seat there well
let's go back real quick instead of
castles here
let's try another move knight to c5 very
aggressive in a way
actually very good as well developing
bishop takes f5 being an intention here
but we have this cool sequence guys this
is why this thematic sacrifice
is very strong after knight takes g7 i
mean this gets
wild king f8 after king f8 there's queen
takes d5 wait
didn't i just sack a piece am i sacking
another piece
i think so queen takes d5 bishop b7
because i'm not taking a rook
and this is still hanging still hanging
queen f5
this is still hanging so he's gonna take
it like you know what hey
i'm gonna take the other piece because
you gave it to me here now miraculously
guys
this is zeros it's in equal position
which is crazy a lot of times in a night
or if you do get these crazy positions
to end in a draw
due to perpetual because of sacrificing
material which is fun
but it ends in a draw many times or
black is not able to to
to defend all the threats bishop c4
threatening queen f7 mate
queen eight beautiful move after queen
eight there's g6
on the board what is this nonsense g6
i'm just gonna take it
or at least you thought you were rick
takes g6 oh my goodness this is getting
out of hand
f takes g6 bishop d4 check these bishops
are monsters here
and we're on a king hunt let's just show
a few more moves here queen check
king g5 there's another check and then
flex real hard and for another check
and then king here and mate and we great
start a new game
absolutely beautiful beautiful attack
there king hunt right that could
definitely happen after the rook g1 move
but that didn't happen he actually went
for a three this is the move from
yesopinko here
stopping b4 from ever happening but at
the same time sacrificing a pawn
for the greater good bishop takes g5 and
after bishop takes you could capture but
your queen's on the back rank still
and this gets pretty active and you
can't play rook g1 so yes pinko says
queen to d2
instead preparing castling attacking the
bishop and i can still play rook g1 in
many cases
bishop takes e3 from magnus and then
queen takes e3
beautiful move of course which is this
is what we did at four queen d2 follow
up consistency
and then queen h4 queen h4 from magnus
here interesting move you're asking what
does this move actually do
is he actually attacking anything over
here actually no he doesn't he doesn't
even have a second piece which you need
multiple pieces for successful attacks
he only has the queen over here to do
things but what he's really trying to do
in some cases could be g5 and queen f4
because castling is happening
so after castling we will have a g5
probably e5 is a little bit scary
because you do open up the d5 square
so g5 looks like a move followed by
queen f4 especially so we can
trade queens as quickly as possible
magnus says i'm up a pawn
i would love to trade queens so after g5
queen f4 would be a thing
but after queen h4 rook to g1 from
yesopenko stopping
g5 from ever happening actually so what
does magnus play he has a few moves here
castling looks very scary here
very scary now looks are deceiving he
actually could have castled here
but g6 is move he chose here g6 and we
understand this
now it does make a weakness around the
king but at the same time it does block
this file
from ever having any kind of trouble
anymore now they will have to play h4
and f5
f4 f5 h4 h5 it's going to be a while so
g6 yeah it makes weaknesses around the
king
bobby fischer says to get squares you
got to give square so we give them a few
squares just to keep this
this this attack at bay g6 and then
castle queen side from yes pinko says
this time
it's time and then queen e7 for magnus
i'm going back because my queen has done
everything that she can do and i need to
defend a little bit
after queen e7 there's f4 now take a
look at white's position
everything's developed we're going for
our attack here and black is still
trying to catch up now
it's fairly equal here but white is
definitely the one pushing for more and
attacking chances
after f4 there's bishop to b7 we're
going to finish developing
of our queen side here after bishop b7
king b1
always good to play king b1 usually it's
just good to have the king in the center
when you cast the queen side
nine times out of ten that's just how it
works after king to b1 here
the best move is actually knight to c5
you would think knight to c6 would just
be great
i mean it's okay it can be played but
knight c5 and actually castling are the
best moves here
castling looks pretty crazy once again i
mean it feels like you're casting right
into mate almost but knight to c5 is
more realistic trying to just keep it
you know hey
we're not going to castle just yet we
want to get our pieces a little bit more
active knight c5 followed by maybe
knight b to d7
or knight to c6 at the right moment but
here's what magnus did
he played knight to c6 guys and knight
to c6
is not a move it is a very scary move
actually knight to c6 he actually missed
yes pinko's idea guys can you find
yesopinko's idea white to move
here it is this is what he did guys
after knight c6 he plays
nice cxb5 oh my goodness whoa that's a
move big feather that is a move knight c
xb5 this is a very common thematic
sacrifice that you would see just like
the knight d5 ones
is so much fun sometimes playing from
the white side of the nightdorf
because you're able to do these kind of
moves knight takes b5 just completely
missed by magnus here
as wha it's sacking a piece what do you
mean like what what is this move
well he does take it and then after
knight takes c6 here
sometimes you would take on b5 to put
the pressure on d6 is what you would
think his idea was
but actually his idea was after knight
takes takes now queen to c3 wow look at
that and what they say is loose pieces
lose games
what's loose well loose means undefended
so anything undefended after g6 here
this was already there this is an
undefended piece so any other undefended
piece hit by with a double attack
we'll be able to get something back here
well magnus finally says all right look
hey you know what you got your pawn back
cool
you can have it castle he gets out of
the way my king's finally castle here
he kind of has to do that and then queen
takes c6 we get our material back
and then this beautiful move from magnus
here actually says look i'm not going to
sit around
and just wait to be wait to be attacked
d6 is hanging you can have it
he plays d5 here great move actually
beautiful move as you would expect
anything less from
the world champion d5 e takes d5 here
because we're just going to take this
pawn and now actually
currently currently right now we're
actually uh up a pawn
one two three four five and then one two
three four
five six currently whites up a pawn so
after he takes d5 you would think maybe
just captures back or threatening the
rook played in the queen
which he does rook after c8 beautiful
move here okay after rook after c8
there's not many moves for white to make
here you always want to play aggressive
if you can and just try to keep the
initiative flowing and going in your
favor
after rook after c8 hitting the queen
you don't have many squares queen takes
b5 might run into just more
trouble here and you have a pass pawn in
a way so he just pushes it
great move here d6 now you have two
options move the queen
or take this one let's see what happens
if you take captures here well you might
as well just resign
that's not a move start a new game but
let's see what happens after rick takes
he said c6 we have to take our queen
back when now d7 is hanging
okay let's just move it uh not a move
start a new one big fella work check
that is not it that's game over on the
spot so that doesn't work okay well
we're going to go back
well then actually it was funny it's the
best move
believe it or not guys but one of the
best moves was rick a7
which is just not a movie just queening
here you're just queening but then
after rick to c7 we have bishop takes b5
hitting tonight and then rick the eight
and we're cleaning
this is not good we're into defense i
mean this pawn's about to queen
terrible game right so he says i'm not
going to take that i know better
he plays queen to d8 here actually
controlling everything pretty nice the
queen can swing over to this side of the
board
and for a fraction of a second here but
for a little bit it actually looks like
black is actually attacking white
basically black is the one attacking
white in many cases here after queen d8
queen takes b5 very nice move here i'm
just getting out of the way
and he says you know what i'ma let you
have your attack here now
think about this guys in in games if
you're gonna have trades or before you
actually
reach an end game here's the thing to to
realize and think about you have to look
at the pawn structure
what is the overall end game gonna look
like check this out these three pawns
are what
all passed how about this one a fourth
pawn you got four
past pawns how many times do you get
four pass pawns like
what kind of game is that right so after
queen takes b5 there's rook
c to ba attacking the queen once again
queen has to go somewhere so he goes
queen to c4
just staying around this pawn is his
idea rook takes a3 from magnus here as
he's going to take the pawn
get that pawn back so now we're down to
three pass pawns queen to c7 hey look we
want to trade as quickly as possible
we would love trades and magnus says uh
no no trades today
not not for you big fella queen to ea
and now check this move out right here
guys
very aggressive move i actually like it
it's attacking and defense at the same
time it's beautiful actually
it's it's just harmonious with the rest
of the position this piece needs to be
active or at least more active
it's pretty active on the g file but
it's even better if it can swing over to
the queen side
rook to g5 now we want to keep some
trades up because the more that we trade
now
white's definitely looking for trades
because we have three pass pawns
if we trade off the rest of the pieces
this is game over like this is going to
be over soon if we're able to clean
these pawns so rick to g5
and we live just to swing over to the
other side rook to g5 and now rook to a4
beautiful move here actually just
getting out of the way really rooked to
b4 being your thing
and just trying to reroute some pieces
rick a4 rook a5 we're avoiding trades
we want it to double so he gets the
double here and now
b3 we're not going to let him attack us
this rook is actually trying to help now
we have rook a3 or rook a2
and we're okay this rook sack doesn't
work so we're doing fine
now he plays hey rook 4 to b7 we have to
get this queen out of the way now this
queen's annoying
but look at this position stop and look
right here look you know look
both ways before you cross the street
here white is actually in the driver's
seat in all cases right now magnus is
just trying to hold here
trying to hold bishop f3 knife is anyone
to hold this position
with black it will be the world champion
because this is definitely a very ugly
looking position
bishop f3 is coming three pass pawns
active pieces our pieces are only on the
seventh and eighth ranks this is very
scary for magnus
queen to c3 there's queen to d8 as he's
trying to reroute do some things here
maybe rook to c8 as well but you got to
make some moves
so he plays queen to d8 and we start our
attack says jesse pinko
bishop f3 hitting the rook the rook is
hanging on b7 so
what does he do he just moves it rick to
b4 attacking f4 at the same time
and now we go back to c7 says jessica
pinko time
to penetrate the position queen to c7
and queen f6
saying that okay we're going to do
something we might even be threatening
to sacrifice in some cases
so he says no not today bro rook a8 so
if you do sacrifice you won't be able to
take twice
not at all because you're going to have
to trade something rook a8 and that one
rook is gone now after rook takes bishop
takes a a
and then magnus blunders he blundered he
is human
half human the other half world champion
you know whatever right he's the
excellent the best chess player in the
world right but bishop takes a5
he is human as he blunders and plays
queen f5
that is not a move here guys one of the
best moves actually
was really knight fa you had knight b6
and rook b5 all of these are still
losing by the way
but queen f5 was the worst of the losing
moves
queen f5 here after queen f5 threatening
of course rook takes b3
being the intention we play king to b2
to get out of the way and then rook to
b5
and there's really not much else to do
here guys because there's going to be
check on the back rank anyway
i mean you can't stop this you can't
even defend the knight if you move the
knight we push it
this is a disaster already disastrous
rick to b5 and then we have queen takes
d7
attacking the rook in some cases of
course well we can take and then push
and push
pretty cool it's pretty cool you
literally could sack this queen but
we're not going to do that
he actually just plays uh actually after
queen takes d7 rook to c5
then there's rook to c1 defending c2
here beautiful move of course
um defending the pawn so there's no
mates or anything queen takes f4
from magnus here maybe get some checks
off here but let's see how he finishes
this yesterday says queen e8 check
king g7 and then d7
and that's it magnus resigns the world
champion resigned
in this position as andrea yessipinko
walks away
today's winner in this exciting game
what a big game from a very young player
strong player at that that was crazy
here guys i mean absolutely amazing
attack starting with g4 early on so you
can take notes there guys
but this was today's game of the day i
hope you enjoyed it i'm national master
james canty the third here
with jess.com and we'll see you guys on
the next video
[Music]
you